one of the biggest games of this half of
2015 is going through its beta its
second beta but its first beta of 2015
erin thompson ryan schubert battlefield
experts here in the office are here to
talk to us about battlefield hardline
first of all you've been playing this
beta you guys play all of the
battlefield games here in the office and
what do you think about this pale in
comparison to what came out after e3
last year it's a big improvement
visceral sat down with their original
beta which was supposed to be an actual
beta yeah and they got a lot of very
aggressive fan feedback and they took
that fan feedback and just really really
tightened all like the mechanics and the
experience they've done a really good
job and listening to their fan base has
anything changed like majorly in terms
of the game modes available guns
available have stuff plays or is it like
the intricacies of the game modes them
yeah so there was a huge change in high
snowed where what used to happen is
people run in they grab the cash then
they'd immediately go to the exit points
and win and that was just was like over
in an instant so they basically made the
exit points also random like they rotate
around map and they you have to capture
them okay cool over time excuse me so
battles happen but in the bank and then
at the capture point along gates the
matches right even playing as well for
bit today yeah a little bit today the
heist feel a little bit chaotic but I
feel like it's also everybody still
learning you know I get it seems to have
an interesting sort of balance of like
an objective based mode with more or
less a team deathmatch because that you
know there's players that are trying to
move the cash to the escape point but
there's also just a constant firefight
happening all over the place yeah cause
like in the case I don't know if it's
gonna be different on the other maps
when they come out but like in this case
the map is small enough that we're the
police spawn and where the criminals
spawn like they're not that far apart
you're going to be back in the firefight
in a matter of moments excellent that
was once every way out it worked me a
bit about the other beta was trying to
get back into the sort of the big melee
that seem to be happening in this sort
of area at Chris your seminar worked on
a really good video last week about the
sort of the core mode that's in
battlefield hardline what are the
problems maybe with three and four was
that they didn't really have their sort
of tent pole this is the thing you want
to be playing can you speak to that like
what was the what did you like about
heist so actually the mode that I wrote
about was hot wire heist seems like oh
it's cops vs criminals it's going to be
the bank robbery it's gonna be you know
some variant on that kind of thievery
it's going to be everyone tries to grab
money faster than other people but I
think in terms of the battlefield
experience Hotwire is going to be the
one that people gravitate towards it's
going to be the one that creates those
crazy moments it'll like way more often
that really sort of fuel people coming
back to see what's going to happen next
wait what so what happens in our hot
wire is basically conquest with cars as
the capture points so their mobile and
so instead of going to a position like
setting up defending it or assaulting a
position and that's a set place you have
to chase down a car you have to hop in a
car and in order to gain capture points
you have to be driving it at like 30
miles an hour yeah so you can't just
Park it behind a building so there's no
like static State in hot wire there's no
like oh I'm just gonna sit on this
capture point until the enemies come and
then gunned them down cuz you have to be
driving and by natan you know you could
be trying to do your loop out on the
side of the map but you're gonna like
stuff is going to be happening so I
think for me the thing that frustrated
me about conquest was the like so many
of the players would get in there
capture a point and then be like what we
got it off to the next point yahoo and
then like just about that capture point
whatever and so it was just this
constant churn and I think because
Hotwire those capture points are active
and it seems to really have an aunt to
be that answer for that nervous kind of
frenetic pace and one of the things I
remember you saying before iron when the
trailer for a hard-line first came out
was that you were very critical of the
like vehicle-to-vehicle grand combat
that was in battlefield 4 and you were
saying I wonder how they're going to be
able to do this because like some of the
weapons for instance wouldn't really
work if they tried to do this in
hardline how do you think they've sort
of managed to nail that mode they're
still fine-tuning the balance but they
were the major changes they did was take
the RPG away from the engineer class
right or the mechanic in this case
because it would one shot light vehicles
and that would basically shut down car
chase
yeah car chases are the most fun thing
to do so you don't want to do that I'm
running into some things in the beta
they probably have to tweak like players
are getting good with putting explosives
on the road and like trip mines all and
trip mines one shotting cars & kareena
so like they may need to even take it a
little bit further but they did a really
good job by taking away the weapon Oh
LMGs also they took that away it made a
ballot pick up just things that would
immediately shut down car chases those
things are now yeah they're battle
pickups so you can find them in the map
yeah and pick them up anybody can and
there's certain spots where they spawn
so they're marked on the battlefield
yeah there are no mini money yeah you
can see them on the mini-map so they it
almost becomes like to me kind of echoes
that early halo thing where it's like
control the power weapons come on
because if you can if you know you have
a reliable access to the RPG then all of
a sudden that helicopter that's coming
in isn't like quite as much of a oh my
god they're in a helicopter we we need
to figure this out oh my god oh my god
it's like yeah no I got that's great the
rocket launchers born like the red
health or something yeah when that plays
a little bit to the game mode that you
and I both loved from battlefield 3 the
the aftermath expansion which was
scavenger and it only appeared in that
one map pack and that was like sort of
that classic style of there were you
started the match with like a hand
grenade and a handgun and a knife and
then you had to find other weapons
throughout the map and there would just
be random pickups of rifles shotguns and
whatever you guys have played like
hundreds of hours of all those games and
you seem to have like a real sort of
intricate and knowledge of them as well
at your criticisms of some aspects of 3
and especially for and have been like
echoed around this office for the past
year at least and speak to sort of what
you think the problems are with for with
frostbite and how you think visceral
have got a kind of a job on their hands
so I think visceral is doing the best
job that they can do with frostbite
there was some really interesting things
like so dice worked on battlefield 4
tried to try to make it work you know
well for a year and it got to the point
where it was almost awkward because
normally I like it when dev support
games
it like literally nine or ten months in
they were just fixing like movement
mechanics and like fixing crashes for
entering vehicles and using repair
torches yeah so like the visceral
engineers took a look at balfour and
they fix some the stuff that they told
me wasn't too hard to fix like just when
they go hands-on just when they got
hands on it like that one of them a big
one was a sound through floors bug where
you couldn't tell by listening where
somebody was in relation to you I talked
to one of the visceral devs and they
were like oh yeah that was not hard we
just flipped some code and it was like
we fixed it well like it was actually
built in the frost yeah and and they
just didn't have the switch throne is
what that sounds like that's crazy but
then they couldn't get rid of certain
things like I don't really want to stare
at a loading screen in between matches I
want to be kidding my character around
and apparently when they try to do that
it's so hard coded into frostbite it
basically either drastically increased
loading times or kind of broke the game
yeah so I think visceral is being held
back a little bit by frostbite I
question at this stage whether frostbite
is keeping up with battlefield and for
that matter battlefront which is now
supposed to be out by you know winter
break yeah they've got quite a lot of
stuff on their hands they're obviously
dice or not working on this they both
said it to the California studio and
they're often Europe doing their own
thing presumably working on battlefront
I do you still worried a little bit
because battlefield 4 was such a
[ __ ] in terms of like the bugs
you said we're there for a year onwards
massive problems not even one like it
yeah silly this day have you gone back
and player I went and played over the
weekend just to practice a little bit
and I was still encountering just bugs I
couldn't wrap my mind around like why
they still existed like you know uh
people you know when you get revived
with the shock paddles yeah you're
sometimes when you get revived you're
the screen is just shaking but it
doesn't stop shaking PTSD yeah and it's
like I call that I made the [ __ ] how I
almost lost this house is still a
problem yeah and like I had a I brought
up a my grenade launcher at one point in
the tube was missing what this game is
now like 15 months old yeah and then
these are like simple bugs but they're
still there
it's crazy when you think that bothell 3
was was pretty fantastic but they've
been making like solid motspur games for
years and years even bad company like
which is often thought of they're like
oh they're like single player for a
because they've been doing Vietnam in
1942 and like you bow 2142 and to didn't
have like single player stuff but like
bad company two is one of the best
multiplayer shooters I by playing on
xbox 360 I think it's the best that
they've done really with like the way
that they had the like map and mode
designs work so well together you know
like the maps that were designed for
rush flowed so well in rush and the
conquest maps float like conquest should
and then when they went over 23 they did
all this sort of purposing everything
for the same you know all the modes yeah
and it's like homogeneously and it
didn't play well you know no mode was
actually no map was actually good for
every mode or even sometimes even a
single mode and to be fair they're split
I mean dice has always been trying to
please to crowds there's an older crowd
that came in during battlefield 2 they
just like open maps mostly hands-off
game just give me the tools and let me
go if I don't meet somebody for five
minutes whatever that you know that's my
deal and then there's a whole generation
people came in on console and played you
know the bad company series and they
expect a much more tight more focused
experienced you know rush sort of
defined their idea of what battlefield
is and battlefield 4 to me the reason
that it failed is because it tried to
please both of those crowds and ended up
with a very bland middle ground
experience yet there was mops the word
big and open but then had like big
internal areas like the close quarters
map pack I always found funny it was
like you guys are taking your unique
selling point and then just saying now
[ __ ] it let's try to call of duty yeah
are a couple of months yeah I feel like
there's a lot of dire talk around
battlefield for some guys who have
played the game for dozens and dozens of
hours like I guess my question is you
know clearly there's their bugs that
persists to this day and that you know
you see them and they just they seem to
be more and more in like baffling the
longer that they are still there but
like taking a step back from you you
know and looking at battlefield 4 with
an eye towards hardline you know
do you like do you think that the
fountain like the core there should be
carried over to hardline or like what
what what's what's significant shifts do
you think will benefit hardline that
they're sort of planning as compared to
battlefield 4 I would say that I think
the more the hardline can be unique you
know with like the heist and the hot
wire modes like the more it can actually
separate itself from battlefield is like
a unique product I think the better you
know and isn't that just just do
something different like don't give me
you know they're gonna have conquests
right but don't make conquests the thing
and like it don't get like I don't want
to have Jets I don't want to be in the
desert somewhere at a fueling station
like you mean like you just so you want
it to be to feel different to feel not
like the three to four because that was
not a yeah I do like the title is almost
them trying to do that as well to be
like yo this isn't just for plus 1 this
is kind of a new experience having a
strong theme is really going to help a
lot to the battlefield 4 cuz was
honestly like generic soldier macdui in
a field yeah like I couldn't tell you
anything like half the time when you
looked at a faction you didn't know who
you were shooting at sometimes you
couldn't even tell it was not your team
so yeah like I see you do for the math
and I know it's a Robert Harrison
nightmare on hardcore servers this
wasn't so hard to be in them it was like
oh they're the dude with the punji
sticks yeah I'm the guy with the Apache
you touched on how it's important the
battlefield hardline has its own kind of
theme it definitely does have a theme
difference to the previous to
Battlefield games but you know looking
at 2014 and a lot of what happened in
the headlines a lot of like rightful
anger or like distrust perhaps of the
police in particular here in North
America like some of the trailers were
coming out for hard line for that single
player campaign seem to be touching on
something that I don't think that
they're particularly totally aware of so
it's the inspiration for hard line is
the police procedural right though yeah
law and order the CSA whatever like they
want to have that kind of television
production and so their story mode si si
si si yeah a fine CBS property right
yeah 2 broke girls nailed it I so that's
like I feel like the multiplayer you
know side of hardline is just too
bonkers to like be in any way compared
to reality right you know but when
you're talking about telling stories
about cops who are corrupting cops who
do good work and cops who are you know
interacting with civilians in this way
and cops were interacting with maybe
criminals this way that's when you
really get in to hitting on what is a
huge issue in America and given the
events of last year is like what kind of
force should be used yeah and of course
so much of video games is about that
power fantasy is about being able to use
force in a way that you know you would
never get to in real life so I think
they really have their work cut out for
them making it you know like tapping
into that but at the same time not
portraying being a police officer as
like carte blanche to do yes or as like
you know at like yeah I'm a wild card
and that's good yeah Dirty Harry taking
the law into your own hands thing yeah I
don't and something like it really looks
like they were trying to create like you
said a police procedural and then what
happened in 2014 like the not just one
instance but like the verb the
incredibly awful amount of instances of
this that happened in 2014 that have
been like been brought to life like they
haven't been in previous years like I
feel like they have like I wonder if
they have had to backtrack somewhat on
what they were doing in that game
because I really doubt that they were
trying to go down the line and it kind
of pisses me off that they're even
trying to do it because bad company is
by far the best single player campaign
they have ever done battlefield 3 I like
this just because it was like popcorn
action movie nonsense and it was kind of
RAD like some of the best kind of cool
like I really thought Paris level was
really great oh boy I was meeting also
was the road is a walk by the time for
came along I was like done one of those
likes ya stop tired be story short
tolerances at different plans for that
kind of stuff but like I was done with
serious story at four so I'm kind of
thinking but I didn't he ever clicked
campaign and all that whatever
I never could bring myself to do it i
just so we're talking all this about the
bet multiplayer and it seems like we're
all interested in hearing about the
multiplayer you don't care you don't
care do we have a hat trick on dome
caring about campaigns and battlefields
oh no I mean this campaign might be
interesting just because it's a little
more stealthy and there actually is a
coherent story to it other than again
like a generic lithography and it does
seem like it's adding a little bit more
player choice to how you get through
yeah scenario a little bit more like bad
company did so that is refresher let's
say let's say I love it you know let's
say I end up really liking the
single-player campaign it's going to be
what eight hours out of a hundred hours
that I play this game it's insignificant
I it's hard for me to fathom how much
money goes into single-player budgets in
battlefield what they know that it's
going to be like a tenth or less of a
player's time it might be like two
percent of a player's time or it might
be most of that flares time because a
lot of people like a lot of people don't
get in with two multiplayer shooters and
the whole battlefield scene can be like
intimidating and so and it also has this
a different kind of cultural
significance not just because of the
cops and criminals things that's taken
on and not because of the current events
in America but also because it is
tapping it it's imitating what is one of
the most popular forms of pop art yeah
the police procedural guess what is
quite a lot of CSIS yeah on CBS yeah so
it'll be interesting to see how it how
it shakes I never watch it does that
mean we get cowboys and Indians on the
next battle phase yeah yeah yeahs next
time i read battlefield make it happen
ha collabos thank you very much
gentlemen for coming on and talk about
battlefield hardline of course we have
to it just a couple of months to play it
for ourselves or you can get in on the
beta right now on the Xbox one I hear it
doesn't look as good as a wood on PC I'm
not gonna lie there were some aliasing
problems at least box aliasing problems
exclusive head to the xbox one let us
know what you think about real hard line
in all of its as there is much empty
yeah exactly mar 17 RT 17 but let us
know tricks did right is this yeah happy
st. Patrick's Day you don't know that's
killing back
let us know what you think on the
comments below